-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
And this is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
Now let's get to the news.
President Biden spoke on
the phone yesterday with
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin,
and they were
able to work out an agreement.
It's now President Manchin
and Senator Biden.
When asked by reporters after
speaking with President Biden
about the $2 trillion
spending bill,
if the measure will
pass this year,
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin said,
"Anything's possible here."
Okay, but to be clear,
that's not good news.
When someone says,
"Hey, come to my party tonight,
anything's possible,"
you're leaving in handcuffs
without your pants.
According to newly released
records, Donald Trump Jr.
texted then-White House
chief of staff Mark Meadows
during January's Capitol attack,
urging him to make
President Trump
condemn the violence.
Then he texted again,
saying, "Fine.
I'll tell him myself.
Just give me his number."
The records show that
then-White House chief of staff
Mark Meadows
also received a text from
Fox News host
Brian Kilmeade that said,
"Please get him on TV,
destroying everything
you've accomplished."
That is a shocking revelation.
They had to beg Trump
to go on TV?!
Fox News host Laura Gr--
Ingraham -- excuse me --
also texted Meadows
during the Capitol attack
and said President Trump needed
to tell the rioters to go home.
Mostly because her show
comes on at 10:00,
and they're her target audience.
It's been a few weeks since
the World Health Organization
designated Omicron as
a new COVID variant of concern,
and it appears to be
rapidly spreading
around the globe.
But there are still a lot of
uncertainties about
how dangerous it is.
So let's take a look at
what we know so far
in a segment called "Getting to
Know the Omicron Variant."
♪♪
And, finally...
This has been "Getting to Know
the Omicron Variant."
[ Cheers and applause ]
According to a new study, rocket
scientists and brain surgeons
are not smarter than the
general public.
The study consisted of
two photographs.
During yesterday's White House
press briefing,
Fox News reporter Peter Doocy
said that the recent
Christmas-tree fire outside of
the network's
New York office caused a
half-million dollars
worth of damage.
That tree cost Fox News
half-a-million dollars?
Did they decorate it
or sexually harass it?
And, finally,
according to the latest numbers,
Apple is set to become
the world's first company
with a market value
of more than $3 trillion.
And almost $2 trillion
of that comes from
chargers left in hotel rooms.
And that was
a monologue, everybody.